[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
jerry jones
i like yeah no
someone say titanic
the titanic yeah yeah
i don't know why i'm pumped on that
but i like that
just dying
[ __ ] hold on i'm doing i want to
think about titanic because that's
pretty funny it's funny to be like let's
go on a trip and then you die
you know what i mean like that girl
it was
that was kind of her titanic
except jack got rose this time
there's only room for one on the van
[Applause]
he did the right thing
no it's not good are we not allowed to
make fun of that
i think we should be allowed to make fun
of that girl yeah we're all good yeah
shut up lady
don't make me come down there
take you in a van trip
don't make me take you to a state park
lady
[Music]
i will say that what's tough about it is
they were making that [ __ ]
video of them like we're going on a
journey like that youtube video and it's
funny because every time i see one of
those i'm like [ __ ] i hope they die
and then this one it was like oh [ __ ]
isn't it is that guy dead is he in a
swamp dead right now is he on the loose
he's hiding in the swamp
no dude he killed himself
if he went all right
props
look
fellas
i'm talking to the fellas real quick
you know when your [ __ ] is getting a
little yappy
and you're like i'd like to strangle her
and then uh
hide in a swamp and kill myself
every once while somebody has the balls
to do it
all right that was titanic next
you guys want to hear just a horrible
story sure
um so i i was at the airport and um
someone told me a story there's a 911
was it no
[Laughter]
lesbian porn is for like 13 year old
boys and that's it
i haven't watched lesbian i haven't
whacked off the lesbians and because you
need a [ __ ] [ __ ] dick
to be clear it's the shame that i enjoy
that's probably the best part of
watching a lady eat ass
what a disgusting shameful act
against god's will
[Laughter]
you know
oh man that's a mistake
it's just a mistake
i used to i used to get like like
like
[Laughter]
they just wanted to keep drinking
i'm big with content okay yeah yeah
i wish i could have showed i wish i
could have showed what the thumbnail of
the special was gonna be
that morning he messages me that morning
he goes hey is this good and it's just
like a picture of like upshot of his
nostrils
there's no [ __ ] clue who it is it was
unbelievable i have no idea what i'm
doing i thought it was i thought it was
the netflix thing for love on the
spectrum
[Laughter]
it was it ups there's no way that it was
you i had no clue do you have a bit of
michael in me
[ __ ] i was on season one thank you when
it came out
he's been trying to get me to watch this
hold on before we get into this yeah
there's a better one it's called the
special yeah dude the specials
[Laughter]
yeah let me explain this story we're
talking about people with down syndrome
and they're doing reality shows about
yes okay there's a house full of people
with down syndrome yes first off once
you watch it you realize dudes with down
syndrome are the bros they're the best
dudes on earth of course all right yeah
so this dude named sam he's got down
syndrome one of the episodes they're
gonna take him to a lady boys show
a burlesque show of ladyboys and he is
pumped dude he's got the flyer he's like
he keeps coming up to the camera like
sexy dances
and everybody's like relaxed
and he goes and then everybody keeps
telling him it's like no they're
actually men and he's like no they're
not
the whole time he's like trust me
they're not and that he's talking to one
of the one of the house like chaperones
and he's like sam
they are they are boys and he's like
don't be rude
he's trying so hard and then he goes
what if one of them tells you they have
a penis and he goes
i'd be fuming
there you go why would you be mad
because i have no idea
that's the bro i'm still going so he
gets they take him to the show he gets
in there the camera's on him the girls
come out and are dancing he's holding a
soda he looks back his boys like
they show his face like yo i told you
the girls are sexy
and then one of the one of the dancers
takes their mask off and starts singing
like a man and they cut the camera to
him and he's just sitting there like
he's still being polite
but then a minute later all the dancers
come back out the camera custom he's
like
i have zero credit except i never paid
my student loans uh but that's what i
defaulted on that doesn't hurt your
credit it doesn't no student no
scholastic uh [ __ ] debt doesn't hurt
your credit really yeah
that's it's a great law because that's
why people like i'm not gonna [ __ ]
sure who are you gonna clip me for go
trying to get education so i can get a
job yeah it is all you have to do is not
pay it yeah or you pay a little bit i
paid all of it at once oh oh you did
yeah once i got snl how much oh really
as soon as i got us now i bought a chevy
cruze and paid my student debt bowling
and then was back to zero career wise
i knew that was coming
snl right away yes
it's me i was fired from snl
actually
not for the reason you heard it's
because i'm terrible at improv
and uh this is this is gonna be bad
they didn't care north korea
i was i i like it i like what's going on
there
i support it i liked when trump
and kim jong-un
where's the deal now whatever it was my
guy dude
you see him drop a couple lbs
show back up everyone was like oh
there's videos of him riding a horse
which is about as funny as it gets
i wrote a scooter here and i probably
looked like a fat guy on a horse
there's something about when somebody's
balance is that high off
it's just way up there
yeah i like north korea and i support
them
and yeah if they decide to nuke south
korea
[ __ ] would be tight
that would be lit
i support
a war i guess that's called improv folks
[Music]
i just wrote this song what do you tell
me to think okay
rock me mama like a wagon real rock me
mama any way you feel hey
mama rocked me
rock me mama like the wind and the rain
rock me mama like a southbound train hey
mama
what do you think
[ __ ] gay
we were talking about that with with uh
cannon the other day when he was talking
about the licking buttholes and he's
saying he's in he's been googling women
lately
you say huh oh yeah i disagree with
girls giving rim jobs yeah that's my
i'll turn the porn off really yeah
rude
what are you gay dude
you like to see guys get their ass eaten
sure
i'll [ __ ] watch anything yeah i will
literally watch anything
no i've i've said i've not i've searched
it before i know this podcast is
lighting loafers like this a little
fruity [ __ ] dude i'm straight as [ __ ]
i'm so straight i'm homophobic
that's how straight i am
i don't even like thinking about i hate
i'm so straight i don't like even
thinking about other stuff
what do you think about
during the day like when these thoughts
cross
notre dame toledo this week
we got toledo coming into town
so many penn state guys right now in the
comments like
all those [ __ ] well it's funny too as
a notre dame fan a catholic it's hard to
be like those [ __ ] pedophiles
i don't know what it is
about the tick tock well it's because
they're hot girls but i like those
dances yeah i like the face also you say
make the like [ __ ]
have you ever seen one in the wild
you know have you ever seen one
happening what about when they change
outfits oh when they jump never know
what's gonna happen yeah yeah yeah like
you see him in the baggy stuff and
you're like what's going on
i don't think where is this gonna go
yeah she probably doesn't have huge
tickets but she perfect
oh my god she's perfect
and they surprise you every time they're
always perfect did you ever listen to
ads on hip-hop stations
uh no i'm a big hip-hop station guy
right we didn't i was in mechanicsburg
when i was listening to the radio we had
no hip-hop
all the ads are like do you need a bail
bondsman
and you're like what the [ __ ] like swear
to god those are the acts of now where
they're like man
are you tired of not getting a vaccine
you ever had any really big dick
injuries to be honest
[Laughter]
yes
yeah this is my first this is my first
penis injury did you ever do a penis
crash no what's that it pops out you go
just like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah see that's what happened
except this time there's a fingernail
there yeah yeah yeah
the girl oh he's it's funny what we both
talked over each other three times in a
row
yeah
it was like the opposite of a harmony
so what were you saying i'm sorry no you
go ahead i was saying you encountered
the mythical vagina
dude a tooth vagina
true
she could have it and she lied about her
hand
she is a demon
the
[Laughter]
yeah she's going to be delighted to hear
this but it's just this whole ordeal
yeah yeah well yeah that can go one or
two ways sometimes you could get like oh
you know you're joking around but you're
just joking around about you getting
sliced yeah my penis was cut yeah
anyway i hit you with that hail razor
dude did you have to call for new sheets
no it wasn't like that
towels i was just like holding the fish
yeah yeah i gripped it
yeah
i really did i applied tight yeah i was
worried
i was like no it's not bad and then i
went i ran into this i went to the hotel
bathroom and i let go for a second i was
like it's actually pretty bad
it's very bad
so yes
that's good well now you guys know my
secret i have it damaged
can you fly with the damaged penis uh
i'm going to go through that they're
going to see it like jesus
sir step inside step aside
something's wrong you're hiding
something in your penis dude
but i thought of cartoons yeah they do
just randomly select me and they're like
we have to touch you there i'm gonna be
like no my penis is actually cut
you're not gonna be able to go in the
ocean in san diego i would i didn't plan
on no that'll heal it out look at me and
uh you're gonna go swimming you might
yeah dude and i will that'll heal you up
instantly yeah you need salt water on
that thing you think salt water is good
for my wounded pee like dead serious
that would heal it guys you could salt
if you have some himalayan dude you
could you could you know i'm not salting
[Laughter]
i've heard of astrology and belly button
rings
i feel like those going to girls yeah
they do the girls are you guys still
getting belly button rings i don't know
i haven't [ __ ] a [ __ ] lately
i'm telling you dude having a puerto
rican daughter is just the best it's
like if some progressive white chick is
like you're racist i'm like am i i'm
making minorities what are you doing you
dumb [ __ ]
i like it sorry yeah yeah really
adding to the [ __ ] minority
population what uh thomas jefferson said
yeah yeah that's how much i love them
but they're like you have slaves he was
like i'm making more i'm making more
exactly i'm making i'm making my
argument
no dude that's how much i love them
cause i'm creating them
i'm not autistic you don't think at all
in the spect have you ever taken a test
or something no for it
no why not take an autism test yeah yeah
what's the test i think you should take
one do you [ __ ] panic at malls
yeah if you told me people with asmr
just panicked at malls i'd be like that
makes sense yeah sure flow of
conversation can be tough sometimes
[Applause]
i think
it's you guys it's our [ __ ] though it's
our fault yeah look one on five one on
five what do you want me to do
definitely what do you want me to do
i'll just entertain all right man i
[ __ ] love avengers
is that that heart shape is that that
hard
turn on when you want yeah that's all it
takes is [ __ ]
because you're acting like we've never
hung out on a not podcast before guys
i'm having fun
i'm glad that that makes one of us i'm
tired of my life
who what else what is the podcast
normally like huh we literally grab a
thing and we bring up a race and then we
say how it's connected yeah oh yeah yeah
avengers is like mexicans why guys
they just keep coming out with more yeah
good formula
what else you got or we explain why
stuff is gay a lot we like yeah we love
that see dude this is a this is my
wheelhouse why aren't we doing this
jokes yeah yeah yeah don't say roasted
yeah that might be a little bit
insensitive roasted yeah let's do a
different one for that bullying that's
better bullying okay um but yeah that's
basically the formula to what we do here
you know and then maybe we'll have an
interesting conversation about a youtube
video that you saw that week right
something that taught you something
about the world and then you know the
guys will probably support it and
encourage you to bring up more
conversations what other movies are like
racist no more movies i like the movies
and races
i'm just realizing right now you're
fully [ __ ] autistic
you never knew it no you never knew it
dude he's normally drunk and that
probably unlocks his like his
personality he's humanity yeah or you
just chalk up any of the weirdness to
being drunk
that's why he stared at me like this for
like 30 minutes
[Laughter]
you're about to see it
what other movies
what else we got on hopeful advice with
bobby kelly and shane gillis uh the
first question is not a question it was
actually a common um request on our
twitter and our social media uh people
are saying you have an amazing
surprisingly donald trump impression and
they wanted to see if you could teach
bobby
how to do the donald trump impression
he's tried a couple times can i hear
yours i don't have one yeah you try to
do it right now one first i'll mimic you
you try no no no you go first
well just give me a sentence that he
would say and then maybe i'll try uh
let's go uh
uh the greatest uh the greatest country
in the world is america the greatest
the greatest country in the world
is america okay
that's terrible
it was terrible that was terrible
it was like marlon brent
well i mean say one do the same line and
maybe i can mimic it so you got to do
the easiest way to do trump is like to
speech trump when he's doing a rally
okay okay because it's just in the
backyard okay the greatest country
the greatest country okay a little bit
the greatest country don't do this do
this
the greatest country
don't move at all right
don't move my body you're supposed to
move your shoulders
the greatest country
sit like that if you're sitting don't
first of all don't
okay so sit like this don't yeah
the greatest
country the best country the best
country
wow what a country wow what a country
a lot of asians
a lot of asians maybe too many maybe two
that's pretty good yeah that was good
what's your mom's name joan oh dude such
great names
yeah that's my great squad phil and john
yeah man yeah but but you when you put
them in like when you talk about them
but you don't tell them about the
special is it the assumption that they
won't watch anyway so you don't give it
no they would watch my mom's excited
about it
my mom yeah
it's kind of me being like a little brat
fat [ __ ] little [ __ ] it sounds like
a fat brat move to not but like she's
excited about stan like my career yeah
but i just i can't handle the [ __ ] 65
year old woman questions about stand-up
it kills me dude we'll be like now
what's going on is lorne michaels still
helping with the stand-up special and
i'm just like no he's out of our lives
like we gotta just
yeah like you gotta it's always some
crazy like now you did joe rogan
when is he gonna help like something
like that something [ __ ] crazy but in
those instances don't you wish you could
just be like well let's call joe yeah
let's ask have jones see what he can
pull out of joke
because genuinely it like would work on
a very like like sweet level for calling
joe being like joe what it what can you
do for shane
like what great content now what's your
lady is she how long have you been
together uh a couple months like five
six oh you guys are in the honeymoon
phase yeah yeah yeah just banging all
the time
kiss her boobs or anything i do suck on
her boobs
[Laughter]
yeah sucker tits and uh
if she gets an abortion i'll [ __ ]
kill her what time is the reservation
cause she's still got like four more
hours
you're gonna be hammered
especially if you go all the way through
you know what's nice she said yay i love
it when you're drunk and not because i'm
pretty mean sober
you got my card you're buying everything
and i'll be drunk about you [ __ ] i
love you
what are we eating
[ __ ] up
some stories you've been telling us on
matt and shane's secret podcast about uh
your girl picking fights are like all
timers she tried to fight me
she tried to fight me on russia ukraine
because she thought i was
she accused she dude
you wouldn't believe this this is like
two days before the invasion
so back when they were i was like
they're stirring this up like there's
something going on people want this war
yeah but you know you know me dude i'm a
[ __ ]
conspiracy
i'm not a conspiracy guy i just have
friends that are that i like so i'm like
yes yes yes yes uh but she
out of nowhere she was like you you
don't think that america should go to
war with russia and i was like
no
i don't want that i don't want war we
should sanction russia i don't want war
and then she just turned on me and then
she texted me like an hour later and was
like i'm ukrainian
daddy yo did i did i explain this in the
pockets her mom
listens to the podcast
and said she's
russian and i was like you lying [ __ ]
now she's bro
dude that was the worst fight i've ever
gotten
plenty of flights with women obviously
when it comes to [ __ ] just a
geopolitical event being like oh you
don't like this and i'm like
no what was the one there was one right
before when you guys were on vacation
too that was the craziest that was the
case you're exactly right so you're just
beautiful fifteen thousand [ __ ]
dollars i got ripped off dude
so i when i was a kid i went to this
five-star resort in jamaica everything
was paid for i thought it was
all-inclusive just because it was on the
rich people i was with room so i was
like this is the best resort of all time
so i went back and now it was my card
where are you at half moon half moon
yeah yeah i've been there baby rules
yeah
so
yeah that's sick [ __ ] rules yeah i
think i'm going back to half moon next
month it's incredible so i was at half
moon we're having dude we're literally
we're the only ones there because it
just opened after coven like past
november
and we're at like a candle at dinner
overlooking sunset
caribbean sea
and i don't know what we've been day
drinking
she's a drinker too so literally we're
like let's go on vacation i'll do this
blackout
it's a nightmare
we're sitting at this
gorgeous [ __ ] location and we're the
only ones there there's people playing
[ __ ] steel drums and [ __ ] and then
she's like you if we started talking
about the lady who got killed uh out in
the brian yes um what's his name killed
his girlfriend oh oh his country blind
girl
brian yeah out of nowhere she's just
like you don't even know how old brian
laundry is
and stormed off
it stormed off
like we were having a nice day
she's like you don't even know how
[ __ ] old brian laundry is
i was like
what happened
she stormed off she got like halfway
what she is good at is accepting when i
call her out yeah so i was like yo this
while she was walking away i was like
that's the craziest one you've ever done
she knows it like she turned around and
then she found a real fight like a
minute later there was like a real fight
and she was like yeah all right
she found it
there's an ocean of oil
and i'm the only one who can get it
they just she struck oil
she's like you still follow your ex
[Laughter]
how do you know her instagram yeah
that
dude
there's no better place on earth though
to have a woman's storm off than
a five-star jamaican resort just three
jamaicans behind a bar watching just
like don't worry about that
let's get [ __ ] up
europe's more stringent about web web
security too yeah who the [ __ ] is this
guy there's been a guy that's been
banging outside the door and screaming
[ __ ] it's another whop true i mean we're
right next to a kitchen too so true the
water in there it's me
shut up you're getting the brushes on
they live for the rush dude gardening
knows gardening worked in a [ __ ]
italian yeah you worked in an italian
pizza shop yeah i worked for wops too
they do love screaming they fight they
fight all day in the kitchen they freak
they spaz every day dude they're
ridiculous your wife's a mulligan
all right that's my last black joke no
italians do you say that it's good i
know i know i've seen the movies classic
italian joke
yeah which means eggplant i believe it
does yeah oh really yeah was that
another one
i got some things to say if she was such
a bad so bad giving [ __ ] why was i
so scared that she was actually going to
do it
like would you be nervous going in yeah
hell yeah dude i was the walk up to
where you were like 24th i was terrified
that she was gonna suck my dick
like i was so scared that this porn star
was gonna be like all right fine he also
probably left those cameras on him and
like she's not that that would have been
she ended up hitting me with the she
kind of like she gave me a hug and she
was like i gotta talk to my lawyers
first
and i was like right because you're
actually gonna suck anyone's probably
not gonna get it
[Laughter]
take ten percent of my head
[Laughter]
imagine that being those lawyers like so
what kind of law do you practice well i
sign off on a christie mac and suck yeah
that's just the internet bro yeah we
shouldn't have this we're talking about
the internet it's too much for everybody
to have i genuinely think dude
it's just because everybody wants the
clicks it's just fear everything's
yeah it's like kind of a weird form of
fire yeah it just spreads real quick and
everyone's like oh did you hear oh that
[ __ ] and the next day they're just
like i wanted something totally
different yeah i think yeah i think
you're right dude i think this is uh
just watch sports drink true
dude so i i thought government comes to
take me away that happens dude i i
thought about this today i was i was
reading the book i finished the book so
look character
what oh like a rock dude the government
comes to my house
oh they're not getting me dude
if they welded my door shut i wouldn't
know for four days
just go back like this door's stuck i'll
just [ __ ] chill i need more blizzards
today's podcast is brought to you by
dairy queen
have you been welded into your house by
the chinese government we were in high
school i went to high school in florida
yeah we would just like
people that was what what they would try
to sell you on to go to
any one of the schools they'd be like go
to fsu because the girls are
unbelievable why why what is it about
just [ __ ]
yeah they were mean they were mean to me
because i was wearing a notre dame shirt
and i'm pale they criticized me for
being pale what did they say to you they
said have you ever seen the sun
freak
guy called me a homo
one guy said i swear to god one got one
crackhead yelled from his balcony you
probably voted for biden
wow yeah
nice which actually hurt that one hurt
that hurt i did look i didn't yeah you
know but that's an insult
that's an insult that's like you are a
[ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean that's pretty
sure what do you say you can look at
someone and be like [ __ ] biden voters
oh dude
whoa yeah
dude
he yelled it from a balcony he was it
was him and his hot friends yeah it was
meeting my other two pale
irish friends yeah we got crushed there
was nothing we could do yeah you got to
keep walking right yeah
my friend tried to yell back and i was
like don't yell back we're gonna look
like idiots yes
not only were we getting crushed we were
yelling up
you had a balcony
it's a tough place to talk [ __ ] from the
ground it is true you know and you gotta
have some a1 game to [ __ ] spit back
with that yeah he didn't my friend just
yelled you're white too
and i literally had to shut the [ __ ] up
man shut up i was doing stand up i was
doing an all-black show in philly yeah
black as hell and uh
this one there's there was like one
white dude there i did notice him but i
didn't notice anything about him yeah
and i got on stage and the
he was kind of to my right like behind
me and he just was like
he just started sneezing non-stop and i
was like yo could you shut the [ __ ] up
i looked over and he was
mentally handicapped
i'm so sorry i was like
no dude i'm sorry and the whole crowd
was just like oh what about when i was
like i didn't know he was [ __ ] up and
i was like oh my bad again yeah what
about the magooby's team
after the show
so i was at the goobies in baltimore i'm
gonna be there at the end of this month
yeah and uh go get tickets
there was a there was a guy there was a
table of
mentally challenged dudes it was like a
day out that's a big day out that's my
demo
one flew over the cuckoo's nest i got
tickets
and then
this i couldn't see because when you're
up the spotlight you can't really see so
i saw a shadow of a dude holding onto a
woman's shirt getting let out to go to
the bathroom and i was like yo you guys
see how [ __ ] up that guy was
and everyone was quiet and i was like
all right why who cares the guy's [ __ ]
up and i kept saying [ __ ] up instead
of drunk which would have helped yeah
yeah because you're giving old
terminology
should you guys see that water brain
walk into the bathroom and then when i
saw him go back in i could kind of see
their face this time and i was just like
oh [ __ ] this guy is
very mentally challenged oh you know i
literally i mean in front of everyone i
was like you see this [ __ ] up guy
everyone was like no
this way i wanted to show you this so
that you
are you know just like well informed
i just added bug to my list of pronouns
so here is a very quick tutorial on how
to use bug bugs pronouns
in sentences
okay let's go
i'm meeting up with my friend moth later
uh bug just dyed bug's hair and it's a
super cool green color right now
i think we're gonna go to bug's house
and play some video games
and then i think bugs said
that bug wanted to go to the store by
bug self
i'm done i'm done
i'm done dude if my kid [ __ ] grows up
and makes these tech talks i will beat
the [ __ ] out of him hey
he can take his head and beat it on the
desk and i don't care
i don't like it
what would your dad say if he stopped by
if my dad saw this yeah
i can tell you exactly what he would do
if you played that for my dad i go what
the hell
that's it that's as far as you can go
[ __ ] is this he would just be this is a
different planet i'm i'm losing touch
with this this is you know what i mean
yeah it's a like i'm getting old enough
where i see this and i'm like i'm out
yeah i can't i don't get it because it's
it almost to a degree i think you kind
of go like oh i get i get what's
happening with dave like when someone
goes i'm not he or she you're like okay
but then you're like wait you're bug
that's nice
my favorite is uh you want to go buy bug
self to the store
i mean all you have to do is read this
with like a hillbilly accent it makes
perfect sense yeah i think we're going
to go to bug's house play some video
games yeah i think bug said bug wanted
to go to school by bug sale yes it does
make sense yeah
but also then you realize that's not
bug's not that person's bugs
yeah i don't think this person is
i think
a lot of these are just people with
i think disabilities yeah yeah this
woman has a disability yeah i think
you're right yeah i think well there's
bug part bug self well that's the thing
is like it just sounds i knew someone
named scutterbug
where in virginia of course yeah yeah
well that's the thing i think it sounds
to me like this person wants a cool
nickname right maybe not a pronoun where
we have to conjugate yeah but you can't
give yourself the cool nickname exactly
right you can't show up to school and be
like guys i'm a bug yeah everyone's been
calling me i'm a snake
i ain't afraid of them nobody called
them snakes this is a thing you're doing
imagine pitching this to your father
it's four cameras in a room he'd be mad
yeah he'd be angry that i was doing this
in fact if he knew i was in l.a he'd be
mad
now do you feel comfortable with shane
because shane looks like a kid
who you grew up with in ridgewood he
looks like an irish kid yeah but he
looks like you you look like a kid that
you guys would be having beers like
shane makes sense he's an irish kid
occasionally you know he'll he'll have a
brew in his hand when you see him
there's always like a there's a little
blow yeah if you say stupid
he ruined his life already yeah yeah
yeah
one year yeah yeah yeah
he's that type of kid if you're like do
you want to stella he's like stop saying
that type of language to me what are you
what are we gonna go get gymnastics next
yeah if you notice when i said i'm
freaking white wine like you're because
you know me but he was looking at me a
little bit like what's this guy's
[ __ ] sucking [ __ ] yeah he's like i
didn't know a podcast yeah he's like i
didn't know i was coming to do girls got
to eat what's going on
yeah i mean so you're a kid who doesn't
mean
on the youtube the number one thing that
like my parents actually asked me about
because i was just home in chicago i
spoke about you and then i said yeah a
buddy of mine's putting out a special on
youtube and my mother was like are you
gonna film when you come to chicago i
said maybe i don't really know i haven't
decided about that yet
and she's like you should do the youtube
thing can you make money on it and i was
like well you can but it's also to yeah
not really yeah right because
like you didn't put monetization on the
video yeah and i thought about that i
was like i i wonder what's the rules
like what would you did you do it
consciously or you don't yeah i did yes
you can you could i didn't even add like
a tipping
option why didn't you do that
should we do that now
should we go back and do that no it's
just uh
the tipping thing i think i don't know
how much money i would have made i think
maybe
did ten five ten thousand dollars you
say that dude it's a bummer because
you'll never it could have been so much
watching you think about it is great
[Music]
you